et pour jean rey nimeno chef de mission
adjoint en série pour sos chrétiens
d'orient si l'élection est joué d'avancé
il est nécessaire que les relations
entre les pays occidentaux et la syrie
s'améliore disons que les syriens
ils attendent de cette élection
changement avant tout ils n'ont pas
vraiment de doute sur une issue du
scrutin mais j'espère que ça va changer
et que les sanctions internationales
vont pouvoir être allégée qu'ils vont
pouvoir retrouver une vie plus normale
après dix ans de guerre
voilà ce qu une sauce ou faire qu'on va
entendre de nombreuses années des
bombardements sur leur ville sur leurs
quartiers sur leur maison
et aujourd'hui après ça ils subissent
une crise économique où ils vivent la
plupart du temps avec 15 20 équivalent
de 15 20 euros par mois qu'ils espèrent
qu'après cette élection
justement les relations avec
internationales vont pouvoir se relier
et que la situation du quotidien de
puisse s'améliorer petit à petit on voit
que les pays arabes commencent à faire
un premier pas ce qu'on espère c'est que
les pays occidentaux que puisse faire un
pas également vers la syrie afin que les
discussions reprennent que le contact
soit renoué et qu'on puisse trouver une
solution à cette situation qui est
terrible pour les siennes à plus de 80%
selon maintenant vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté et donc voila mail même si
comme je vous disais l'issue de cette
élection certes la connaissance de la
connaissons tous le but vraiment c'est
de le trouver un contact avec avec
l'occident pour pouvoir trouver une
solution à ce quotidien terrible cian
actuellement